[Musique]
cette exposition elle vise à revenir sur
70 ans d'histoire d'un campus
scientifique au campus du cnra de
gif-sur-yvette au travers des
différentes activités qui ont été
accomplis tout au long de cette décennie
de manière à rendre accessible un
certain nombre d'éléments au grand
public alors faire comprendre à l'avis
scientifique mais aussi humaines
techniques les échanges qui ont pu avoir
lieu sur sur ses sites de recherche qui
existe maintenant depuis depuis la
libération depuis 1946 le cnra c'est un
petit peu pionnier dans cette histoire
puisque c'est le premier établissement à
s'installer en vallée de chevreuse mais
très vite il est rejoint par d'autres
établissements notamment au premier lieu
par le cea puis les universités les
grandes écoles enfin toute l'histoire
qu'on connaît ce qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est à la fois un mouvement
qui s'est fait de manière peut-être un
petit peu décousu d'un établissement à
l'autre mais très vite les liens se sont
faits et notamment des liens du point de
vue humain parce que ba la science ça
repose avant tout sur des femmes et des
hommes et ce sont eux qui créent la
science sont eux qui créent les liens
entre les établissements et aujourd'hui
encore il y a eu sur ce site un certain
nombre d'événements marquants de tout
point de vue que ce soit scientifique
que ce soit humain et des visites de
politique donc c'est vraiment un site et
une une une vie foisonnante tout au tout
au long de cette période que ça soit
l'acquisition de 1946 qui implique des
personnalités comme frédéric joliot
curie ou
ou d'autres que ce soit les années 60
que j'ai eu l'occasion d'évoquer dans la
conférence qui précédait et puis les
l'élan qui a été donnée à ce moment là
autour de la recherche que ce soit les
années les plus récentes les découvertes
qui a été fait à j fossiles et les
progrès dans le cas non même des
médicaments dans d'autres domaines donc
c'est vraiment une vie foisonnante qu'on
aurait beaucoup de mal a résumé en très
peu de temps et qui méritait du coup à
la rédaction d'un ouvrage en parallèle
de l'exposition de tous les événements
qui pouvait avoir lieu
pour ses 70 ans
l'objectif de l'ouvragé c'était de
revenir sur 70 ans d'histoire mais c'est
aussi un moyen de réfléchir à tout ce
qui va se produire par la suite ça en
fait c'est un coup d'oeil dans le
rétroviseur
l'ouvragé l'exposition et d'autres
éléments un coup d'oeil dans le rétro
pour permettre de construire la suite de
cette histoire qui je l'espère je le
souhaite je le pense même sera aussi
rayonnante que les pages précédentes
[Musique]